hi I'm Reginald Lucien watts and I'm
going to take the autocomplete challenge
I don't know what it is but I'm going to
figure it out
[Music]
wish me luck
what does Reggie Watts
what machine does Reggie Watts use I use
a line six deal for an electro harmonix
96,000 what language does Reggie Watts
speak I speak the common language of
gibberish French a little bit of German
tiny bit of Spanish and of course
Acadian what does Reggie Watts used to
loop well I already answered so this is
getting a little redundant Beach what
app does Reggie Watts use on his phone
well I use mail I use stalks I use
Safari what does Reggie Watts - well I
do whatever I can to make America a
better place to allow the world to see
yourself as a never-ending stream of
possibilities so that the future is
Reggie Watts murid I'm not married I'm
not is Reggie Watts British yes I am
British but I've really perfected the
American accent in a way that kind of
allows me to to kind of bleed it and so
I'll just kind of blend and bleed into
whatever situation I'm in so yeah so I
am British thank you it's Reggie Watts
and pitch perfect to now just kidding
I am is Reggie Watts hair real you know
like if you're Germany you're like hey
hair real you know is Reggie Watts
single yes I'm single and by myself
right now just me is Reggie Watts d.add
not yet although I could be I've thought
about that several times like you know
like when I've gotten near misses or
near calls and I'm like maybe I'm just
living out the rest of my life after
I've died and
don't know the difference I don't who
does Reggie Watts
weird al' yankovic probably can do a
pretty good Reggie Watts who is Reggie
Watts bass player Reggie Watts bass
player is one of the funnest apps that
you can use it really allows you to kind
of guess what kind of a bass player
would Reggie Watts use so definitely
check it out some really cool fun stuff
who does Reggie Watts hair I hear a lot
of people I mean I hear a lot of things
around town obviously there's a lot of
hair say I hear a lot about the future
and I really hear about what we're going
to do to solve this water crisis right
who does Reggie Watts look like I get
Antonio Banderas a lot oh also Seinfeld
when I'm cleanly Chauvin and I'm on
stage with under the right lighting
conditions Jerry Seinfeld
[Music]